[Musique]
les gens parmi vous dominer les
nominations pour tous les galas de
l'adisq sans viande neuf nominations
même si vous êtes un vieux routier
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour vous tout
ça pour un vieux comme moi je voyais
tire un peu ma réponse mais pour un gars
comme moi qui avais pris 5,1 entre deux
albums dans deux années de sabbatique où
je m'étais vraiment retirer complètement
c'est facile de faire un être dans son
esprit une petite pensée du genre est ce
que je suis à ce binz que je suis encore
dans le coup des trucs comme sauter
parce que voilà on sait pas trop où
l'avenir nous mène puis d'avoir ces
nominations mais ça me fait plaisir
jusqu'à de plus
réponse super intéressante parce que son
votre nouveau disque
une chanson qui m'a vraiment interpellé
j'ai monté pour vous ça changeait
rapidement eu le succès fulgurant avec
karkwa de lui le succès financier avec
la voix est justement dans cette chanson
j'ai monté il dit quand quelqu'un soit
vous avez perdu un équilibre de façon
professionnelle
c'est allé trop vite c'est pas à les
trouver du tout dans mon coop parce que
le le succès de karkwa a été un succès
de longue haleine et et une ascension
une pente douce et donc au moment de
faire la voix j'étais pas désemparé où
j'étais pas mal outillés pour faire face
à sa fin j'ai quand même fait le saut
parce que le du jour au lendemain
l'anonymat n'existe plus pratiquement
plus les gens tu parles l'épicerie pitch
est il donc ça peut donner le tournis ça
peut ça peut être assez et tour du sein
mais je me suis rendu compte que c'est
plus la passion de mon métier qui peut
m'amener à c'est pas moi c'est plus on
va la passion c'est comme on est
tellement excité mais tellement eu
florrick qu'on enchaîne les spectacles
et ses thérapies finalement un money on
se rend compte qu'on est on est rendu là
on a la langue à terre puis on comprend
pourquoi mai puis autant dans l'amour
que dans le succès que que dole
ce qui vient avec le porter par exemple
le scotch le scotch fruits ah oui on
aimerait oui je suis un amateur de
whisky d'ailleurs j'essaie de me calmer
un peu moi mon nous aux flamands
demandent est ce pull
une croix sur ton cas le jour du
souvenir jean monnet nouvel album
lorsqu'il ya deux chansons j'aime un
mois les points ouvert où vous parce que
vous chantez de plus en plus des
chansons à saveur sociale et vous réglez
vos comptes avec les trolls avec
internet aussi qui ont été parfois très
dure avec vous oui et avec les gens vous
aimez mutilés pour et saisi les bars
étaient ouais pourquoi vais faire cette
mise au point
j'ai longtemps pensé que j'étais un
chanteur qui voulait faire l'unanimité
qui n'était pas nécessairement en train
de bousculer les gens sur des sujets
sociaux et c'était vrai mais qui voulait
plaire d'une certaine manière je pense
que la plupart des artistes en quand
même un peu ce désir et n'est que ça
marche chez pika finalement que les gens
nous aiment
mais pendant ma sabbatiques j'ai pris un
grand qu'un recul donc oublié ma
carrière et sa thérapie
je me suis plongé dans le cinéma de
répertoire dans des pièces de théâtre
est allé voir plus que j'ai consommé
plein d'or différent du ballet et ses
thérapies il ment je suis arrivé à une
conclusion en regardant des films de
pasolini des films qui bouscule la queue
leu leu peut-être le plus n'est plus
grande erreur que l'artiste puisse faire
dans sa vie c'est vouloir faire
l'unanimité
parce que tu te prives de 2,2 d'une
partie de la tribune que tu as pour
régler des comptes pour bousculer le
mans pour faire réfléchir les gens plus
que dix ans c'est beau c'est beau la vie
la vie et l'amour tetris pitié terrain
oui puis je puis je remercie les gens de
mon entourage remercie les gens qui y
avait autour de moi dans dont la femme
qui partage ma vie rebecca makonnen qui
est assez kiki à papa qui est pas froid
aux yeux qui est papa d'aller au bat c
l'accord
bras le pape prend le pas mal fou à nos
questions ça fait dix ans de plus dans
leur album de karkwa
vous êtes resté vraiment chamakh des
projets avec patrick watson à gauche à
droite c'est la pandémie tout est
possible on est vraiment un goût qui on
s'en parle souvent on est vraiment le
goût d'un retour de karkwa ce qui va
arriver c'est sûr ça va arriver ça va
arriver
oui mais pour l'instant on a des
échéanciers tous et chacun fera soit
justement était entré cogiter sur un
gros album avec marie pia qui est sorti
puis qui est excellent au même moment où
je lui demandais viens viens travailler
sur la suite de cars la nuit sont en
huit ans parce que l'afflux de sang
vient parce que la suite est en chantier
et même très avancées
c'est vraiment le fun je suis hyper
excitées sa cerveau complètement
ailleurs
donc ça va être vraiment le fond tu
passes j'ai très hâte d'entendre la
suite à votre album
quand la nuit tombe et je vous dis merde
pour lagarde l'a 10 je le prends je mets
ça dans la poche de derrière qu'est-ce
qui croire
bon
[Musique]